[Music]
and now
you don't have a baby but you have a
little dog yeah we don't have a human
baby
yeah no no human babies but i've seen
you with this dog and you love the dog
almost like a little baby so much we
have a french bulldog named patuna fish
petunia fish
we want waiter full name petunia fish
like tuna fish yeah
we want i wanted to name her i wanted to
name her tamara petunia fish because
tamara toony
plays medical examiner warner on uh svu
anyone no all right so petunia fish is
her full name
toonie tuna fish it's a white dog the
fish it's an
all-white french bulldog yes and she
snores like a drunk old man
it's great she's really great well you
have the reason i brought that up was
because
when i was with you and anna you were
talking about how many nicknames you
have not just toony fish
oh tooty patootie
uh uh creme fresh
uh glass milk dollop sour cream
we go with a lot of the white fur themed
thing
and then sometimes you know a little
monster or you [ __ ]
glass milk glass milk is my favorite
so she's a puppy so we're trying to
train her now
and uh if she pees somewhere like you
either have to catch her doing it or
you've lost a chance to reprimand her so
she'll pee somewhere and anna will be
like you can't yell at her for old stuff
she won't understand yeah you know and i
said look the same goes with me
don't suddenly get mad about something
that happened a while ago i
i don't understand
i'm just like but the rugs dry
i remind uh there's so i could talk to
you for three hours we have to
i've been flagged you're so sad about
this
i am because this show has become how i
how i see people as you know although we
went to we went to dinner we had a we
had a dinner meal
we had a man's meal yeah you you guilted
me into a vegan meal when i wanted
cheeseburgers
so much we were at a place that served
cheeseburgers you could have no but i
can't once you go i'm just gonna have
the raw kale caesar
and the uh vegan chili and then i get a
side of brussels sprouts what are you
gonna get i can't go
cheeseburger
that's like if you gave a thousand
dollars to a homeless man and then when
now ask my friend
is it like that i don't know analogies
are so tricky
if a good order to a waitress is like
money to a hobo then yes
yeah if yeah if the analogy works then
the analogy works
we have time for one question we have
time for one question one question
okay psychedelic mushrooms
yeah like how many times yeah you uh are
you we
no not not recently not in my adult life
no no little mullany tripped you
no i haven't done them in years in uh
i haven't done them in uh years
all right i feel like you've done them
[Laughter]
uh yeah that's how we came up with the
stuff i was a little rascal
i was a little rascal when i was a kid
yeah uh
and uh yeah i took them i like to you
haven't really grown out of that though
you're still
fellaini who me
uh no i'm a leading man uh so oh that's
your message to hollywood that's my
message to the la community
becky sent you out here to talk to me
i'm sure people know that yeah yeah my
manager is this girl named becky
so uh yeah i
took him once with a group of friends
and i
laughed and i laughed and i laughed and
that night we were at a diner and we had
a styrofoam cup
and we poked two holes in it and we put
nickels in there
and then straw hands and we named him
floyd nicholas
and all night we'd talk through him
going you guys want to get some brs
and then you know psychedelics are
strange they
have a reputation where if you take them
you see dragons and stuff and that's not
true
it's more like patterns start to make a
lot more sense yeah
like you'll be like ah that shirt is a
genius
[Music]